greates everyone I'm Ilana and today I'm
talking about something not so
controversial but maybe in a slightly
controversial way it's not an unpopular
opinion that EA's 2018 III press
conference and you you know many of the
press conferences they've held in the
years prior just aren't interesting
yes conference is always the one that
I'm the least excited about going into
e3 even if part of me clings to the idea
that they might bring in dead space
properly even though visceral is gone
now and maybe we'll get skate for but I
digress so I'm in agreement with you if
you say you find days press conferences
lackluster and you don't really get the
things you want from them you get FIFA
you get mad and you get some mobile game
that's been off of a bigger franchise
and then there's that one lovely bit
with a novice European developer
excitedly sharing their indie game
that's how how your need came to be and
I actually brought him with me and then
you get some influences playing a
multiplayer match and you're bored again
I'm with you I disagree with you if you
think this is happening because EA is
stupid or because EA is out of touch I
mean here's a quote from a reddit
commenter during this year's e3 I don't
think I have ever seen a company so out
of touch in this industry it was easily
one of the worst conference in e3 that
I've seen in a long time the only good
thing was unravel to and the way they
presented it which felt very
light-hearted in human the right tone
for the game everything else was
straight-up insane how did this
presentation get approved didn't nobody
on that team realize how bad it was
really well nay ozawa o'night fact is
and it is a weird fact yes press
conferences aren't for you they aren't
for me they aren't even for gamers in
general yes press conferences are for
their actual customers the stakeholders
the shareholders the stock market
Electronic Arts is a publicly traded
company and in my opinion one of the
most business orientated beasts in the
entire games industry and we'll get to
why I think that but at the time of
recording this their stock is worth a
hundred and forty eight point 74 US
dollars coming off of a 34% gain in the
first half of 2018 I'm not gonna get too
deep into the numbers because I find
those even less interesting than EAS
press conferences
but I want you to imagine that Noma as
it is right now as 148 as being a
thousand times more important to ei than
what gamers think and between June 12
and June 14
yes stock rose that means investors were
pleased with EAS press conference that
means they did a good job but they
succeeded they showed exactly what they
needed to with exactly what they had in
mind despite it to game is feeling bad
so let's take a look at why their
shareholders might have thought this was
a good conference and kind of what we
can glean about future press conferences
from why they made the decisions in this
one that they did one thing that I
really want to talk about is the weird
Star Wars bit so the Star Wars name is
Jedi fallen order so it kind of gives
you some idea that you why on earth
would you have a ho sit down next to a
developer and just like weirdly ask a
question and have that be the way that
you reveal the name of the thing how odd
and that was planned if it wasn't
obvious I was fully briefed on EA's
press conference before it went live
that was what they had planned to do
they did it and it was a great idea for
the stock market which is a weird
concept let me explain anyone who knows
about a revenue recognition and such is
going to hate me because I'm going to
simplify this so much but it's part of
my journalism degree I studied marketing
and it's really boring so let's just get
right through it basically as soon as
you market something as soon as you
spend money on making a trailer or
debuting gameplay that thing is on the
market even if it isn't available for
purchase yet if you do that too soon it
throws off your return based on
quarterly expenses and revenues in
essence if EA shows a trailer for the
new Star Wars game in the second quarter
of 2018 and they didn't get the money
back from that marketing expense in the
next say like twenty four months because
the game isn't ready to sell yet that's
something they then have to explain to
their investors cuz it'll piss them off
they've spent money on marketing a
product when our invest is going to see
the return and the revenue earned from
that marketing expense and effort if the
return isn't guaranteed don't market it
the fact that he didn't show up visceral
Star Wars game in action too soon it's
probably the reason the closure of the
studio didn't significantly destroy them
on the stock
it just pissed off dam is basically the
idea is that by asking a developer a
question instead of showing actual
marketing it doesn't throw off EA's
revenue recognition when it comes to
that specific project Star Wars the
fallen Jedi or Jedi fall in order I
don't know the name wasn't even that
memorable I would guess that revenue
recognition is also what makes EAC manty
consumer a lot of the time they released
battlefield 4 even though it was buggy
as hell but if they are projected to
have something out at a certain date and
it'll throw off their revenue
recognition that going to do it anyway
or it's going to look like a huge loss
to shareholder as a quick aside there
was some market predictions for the
rough launch about a front two and the
temporary suspension of in-game
monetization actually having an impact
on the stock market but the impact it
had was far lower than what was
projected it didn't hurt EA very much at
all mostly because FIFA's Ultimate Team
does so goddamn well for the company and
did in that quarter that it just smooth
everything out for them and that's a
quick no brainer worth mentioning yeah
is always going to go hard on FIFA yeah
makes an estimated 1.3 billion dollars
on micro transactions in DLC annually
and FIFA's Ultimate Team alone it makes
EA over 800 million dollars in the most
appealing system ever they make that
money using a virtual Cod system only
needs to be made once and it's a
currency that never runs out or needs to
be reprinted because it's virtual it's
effectively limitless revenue as long as
FIFA takes up a significant chunk of
that conference investors are happy even
if twitter on the side is like sports ID
I don't care how shut up EA now another
point that I would consider a no-brainer
when you're thinking about this as a
stockholder conference and not a game a
conference is the command & Conquer
mobile game segment that lost it like 10
minutes or whatever mobile games are the
biggest global revenue for the games
industry in fact I'm surprised EA only
had one segment on mobile games when
they're making about 42% of the entire
gaming markets revenue with consoles at
31% and PC at 23% in business that 11
percent lead is enormous and it's
largely thanks to how easy it is to
implement micro transactions into the
mobile space demonstrating to invest is
that an exponential revenue stream
exists is the easiest with mobile games
we've got simple games like candy crush
pulling these
scene returns but also it's just the
most accessibility almost everyone owns
a mobile phone there young gamers out
there who were being introduced to
gaming via their phones rather than via
consoles which is really weird to think
about but it's the reality now meaning
that it just has the biggest market and
the biggest audience and if you're
following my lead I don't think it's
surprising what they should have anthem
I don't think it's surprising that they
didn't show what gamers want from bio 8
which is story focused narrative driven
stuff they focused on multiplayer
because that's the thing that is the
most easily made monetizable the most
easily monetizable it's demonstrably
profitable so it makes investors happy
even if it pisses off Damon's ei is fine
so why doesn't every publisher have a
press conference that's similar to EA's
why is Bethesda who have liked some of
my favorite press conferences at this
point so gamer centric instead I think
the difference is between these
individual companies can be answered by
looking at their corporate structures
Andrew Wilson the CEO of EI is profiled
as a businessman with a business
background he says things like the
company is moving from an online
packaged goods company to an online
content delivery service is it weird
that I'm Australian but I just played up
an Australian accent because Andrew
Wilson is also Australian probably
nothing off but the sentence that he
said makes me want to die a little on
the inside but that's the kind of thing
he was hired to say and the reason he is
valuable to the company as a businessman
with a business background selling a
business to investors then you look at
Bethesda they technically don't have a
CEO because that owned by ZeniMax but
Todd how it is director and executive
producer of Bethesda Game Studios Todd
Howard started as a game developer back
in 1994 one's a business man one's a
developer so one has a business
conference the other has a games
conference you can learn a lot about the
goals and direction of a company based
on who they hire for leadership roles
what their background is and even what
their job titles are the one thing that
doesn't make sense to me you know
knowing how EA approaches these things
and how they function as a business is
the EA originals program EA original
games outside of unravel which
technically sparked the program it
doesn't fall under the same category as
the rest of the games in the program do
not net
any profit at all all profit goes to the
depths Deb's retaining IP Deb's have
full creative control ei just helps fund
their marketing I've interviewed
multiple developers about this and have
been able to totally confirm that
there's no catch
there's no sneaky clause but it just
makes me wonder if that one segment
where they have the suite developers
shaking onstage is to appeal the gamers
and gain some good PR even if I would
have thought that that was wholly
unimportant to shareholders it doesn't
it doesn't make sense when you put it
with their company goals alright that's
a lot of talking about business done I
hope that some of you found this
interesting or informative so with that
I'm Alanna stay tuned to this channel
because I'm going to be live-streaming
for the second time ever tonight here on
YouTube a non makes a dot-com / Chara
llamas are the first stream was super
fun so I'm really excited to do it again
that is it for me today everyone I will
see you guys next time